you'll hear the saying you know
we want scandinavian model of socialism
not necessarily what happened with
venezuela
what what are some things that we don't
know about the
scandinavian socialistic philosophy
that i think will shock people once they
find out how the model really works
i think there are a couple of uh points
that need to be made here because
the scandinavian model is the only
socialism that you'd have to say to some
degree
it does work i don't claim that the
scandinavian model
is a failure it works if you are willing
to accept
its strength and its weakness now its
strength
is that the scandinavians are capitalist
in creating wealth
although they are socialist and
distributing it so this is an important
distinction
because in creating wealth the
scandinavians are not socialists they
don't
like in in venezuela one of the first
things that maduro did
was he appointed socialist bureaucrats
to run the venezuelan oil company
now venezuela is the largest oil
reserves in the world more than saudi
arabia
but it takes technical expertise to get
that oil out why
because it's in the orinoco oil belt
it's a certain type of thick
oil that has to be liquefied before you
can sell it on the world it takes a lot
of technical expertise is my point
uh chavez fired all the technical
experts and brings in like bernie
sanders types
you know to run the oil company well
needless to say he runs the oil company
into the ground
it hardly produces any oil anymore um
now the scandinavians don't do that
the scandinavians are a very
entrepreneurial society they encourage
look at all the scandinavian companies
that are doing well in the world
so they have low corporate taxes they
have no minimum wage
you can hire and fire people for any
reason they have less regulation than in
europe and in america
um they don't have any of these no
no inheritance tax i think norway is the
only scandinavian country that has a
wealth tax
so overall and the scandinavians do not
kill the goose that lays the golden eggs
now they do have a big welfare state
but they make everybody pay for it they
have what's called the vat tax that is
the value-added tax
25 on consumption and remember that a
vat tax any economist will tell you
falls heavier on the middle class
and on the poor than it does on the rich
because middle class and poor people
spend more of their money more
higher explain that can you can you
explain that so so if i'm making four
thousand dollars a month versus i'm
making fifty thousand dollars a month
why does the vet the tax the consumption
tax
four thousand dollars a month versus a
fifty thousand dollar a month person
because if you're making four thousand
dollars a month you're going to spend
probably two to three thousand dollars a
month on consumption items you needed to
live
uh and so as a result you're paying 25
of a tax on that now the rich guy is
probably spending more than you
but he's probably spending five to six
thousand dollars a month on consumption
so he's paying more in dollar terms but
proportionately he's paying a lot less
because he spends a smaller fraction of
his money on consumption
that's why the tax falls heavier on
their lower classes
i think it's very important for people
to realize it because even the
scandinavian economist explained that in
your documentary
to say that you if you if you decide to
come here
yes it may be socialism but it hurts the
lower income people
more than it does to higher income
people because you're paying a
consumption tax
much higher than the others that was
very good visual that was given there
for people to know the
math on how it works
[Music]